so let's remember we had to think about
last time we're connected this idea of a
quantity you know an amount of stuff
like it might be time or money or how
much sugar you're putting in a cup of
tea that's a quantity amount of stuff
and then we talked about proportions
which is hey take some of that not all
of it just take some amount of it a
proportion and so we looked at
proportions of quantities last time this
is a proportion of a quantity 25% of one
day what length of time would that be
25% of one day yeah just got one day is
roughly 24 hours so okay so you've done
and maybe you've been thinking similarly
in your brain right you've done a bit of
a conversion here right we said
percentages fractions you can use either
of them to describe a proportion that's
fine same thing and what you've
converted this one day into is a
different kind of unit one that was a
little easier to work with 24 hours so
these are smaller time units that means
there's more of them in the same amount
of time and so it's easier to break up I
suppose we could have I don't know I put
a quite mark there I suppose we could
have broken up into minutes or seconds
but that's a bit overkill isn't it we
can use this what is a quart of 24 hours
it's yet six hours very good that's six
hours so importantly a proportion of a
quantity is just a different kind of
quantity a smaller one usually now today
what we're going to focus on is the same
idea but in the reverse order and in
fact you kind of just did it just now
invent it instead of thinking of a
proportion of a quantity we're going to
think of sorry wrong way around
quantities
as proportions let me give you an
example and you see what I mean so
here's something we could ask which is
to think about these same things but in
the other order I could say and in fact
I'd love you to write this with me
what fraction so I'm asking for a
proportion and then I'm going to give
you a quantity what fraction of the day
is three hours so same kind of situation
right time fractions but I'm asking the
question in the reverse direction now
Jessica you already gave me an answer
very helpfully so Mary can you give me a
suggestion okay very good because we are
thinking and I'd love you if you've got
a color there right
to highlight what the whole unit is the
whole unit in this case is a day do you
see that if I had asked for instance
what fraction of a week or what fraction
of a month is three hours then that
answer would be totally different
wouldn't it but in this case we would
say the fraction is three hours divided
by a day but Marik hopefully said
instead of a day I should say 24 hours
very good now you can see here on the
top and the bottom my numerator and my
denominator I've got the same unit here
hours with hours so they're in fact just
like with normal fractions you can
cancel them you get 3 over 24 can I
write it any simpler than 3 over 24
bravi 1 8 1 8 perfect so you can see
here because we are given a quantity and
we asked a proportion in the end it's
not an eighth of an hour or eighth of a
day it's just one if that's the fraction
okay they give you another quick example
with this time let's talk about
percentages does anyone know roughly
don't have to be exact to the individual
but roughly how many students are there
in our school there are roughly 2,000 so
I'm going to say what percentage of our
school is 450 students
okay we're gonna ask the same question
as before what is the whole unit before
it was a day what's the whole unit here
it's gonna be it's a school our school
which is 2,000 students right so I'm
going to highlight that again one of the
most important parts of answering any
questions like this is you've got to
know what the whole unit is if I asked
you what percentage of cherrybrook which
is a whole lot more people than just our
school then your answer would be
different and this of course is 2,000
students we'll just use that
approximation for now I think we're just
a bit over but that's okay so again in
my answer I'm going to say on the
numerator what number do I put up the
top 450 thank you very much that's the
quantity that I'm sort of focusing on
it's not just 450 it's 450 students and
then what's on the bottom yeah the whole
unit is on the bottom 2,000 students and
even though I'm getting the same object
students here in our is here on the top
in the bottom I like to write both there
just to remind myself because sometimes
you'll be handed different units and
they'll mix together so I've got here I
can write this without the students
involved 450 divided by 2,000 okay now
let's think carefully service for a
second when you look at this you could
probably think of some nice things to
divide through to simplify this make a
simplification okay I want to land on a
percentage so what would I like what
would I like my denominator to be if I
want to percentage ma or do you want to
suggest a different thing rather than
10% okay so I could multiply this by a
Hydra over one and that one hammock
percentage on the end
but remember percentage this is when a
symbol comes from right it literally
comes from over see those two little
circles there
it's from over a hundred that's where
they came from right so we would like
the denominator to be equal to 100 right
this is not 100 yet it's 2,000 so all I
do to this denominator to get it toward
a hundred Louise
okay I can cross out but the zero so I'm
gonna cancel what is that by the way
what am i dividing the top and bottom I
do rice out of zero divided by 10 now
what can I do to go one more step yeah
okay just go ahead yep yep let's do that
divide both the top and the bottom by
two now you will notice this is a little
bit unusual because 45 is not an even
number is it so it won't divide evenly
but that's okay
what is 45 divided by 2 how would we
write it 22 and a half 22 and a half
usually we don't like writing fractions
on fractions but why is this okay why is
this okay Leah what do you think II yeah
we're turning this part into the
percentage so in fact I've just run out
of space so I'm just going to continue
you can keep on going down your page I
would write this as 22 and a half
percent that's what the division by a
hundred is you could write this as a
decimal you could write it twenty two
point five both of those would be
equivalent does this make sense okay so
we're gonna look at some examples of
this can I ask you please to open up
your laptop's to 606 you can see I've
drawn it down a few questions over the
left hand side already
oh do do so here do do you take this
outside
okay that's all right don't let it get
in the middle of your domestic that's
all right
606 is where we're looking and if we
need to borrow textbook please go ahead
[Music]
okay now as as that loads up I'm just
going to kill some time while your
computers aren't waking up I just want
to highlight the two really important
things that are all on the board that
you need to have in your mind as you
have a go through this okay the first
thing is something there is all in
that's what gesticulation
said when we're having a look at this
question here when you're thinking about
quantities and proportions together
because their quantities of things like
time or people or a weight or not an
amount of money what you really need to
get is your units talking the same thing
okay so please highlight that for me you
can see when I think about units like
so-and-so and down here you notice when
I'm talking about quantities and
proportions together I want to be talk
to you at the same units okay so I'm
just going to highlight that over here
same units often the question will be
polite to you and we'll hand everything
to you already in the same units and
that's nice isn't it but it might not be
okay the second thing that I want to
really highlight for you is what I've
got colored in orange what was the main
thing I kept asking you and I had a look
at these two questions what's the orange
underline stuff it's the it's the it's
the whole amount isn't it right the
whole amount here is a day that's what
we were comparing to the whole amount
here is our school two thousand of us so
that's what we're comparing to I'd love
you to start off we're actually even
though this is what I've assigned you to
do can you all just have a look at
question four with me
question four this is the first question
I have not assigned I just want us to
look at it together read question for
just the wording what's the whole about
this three numbers that I can see there
but only one of them is the whole amount
which one is it
25 students you can see in a class of 25
now usually the whole amount will be the
biggest number that you see but not
always okay have a look down to float
your eyes down to your question six
question six World Cup cricket final
look carefully which one is the whole
amount have a look at question six the
World Cup cricket final let's read it
together
it attracted 86,000 people to the game
but 94 thousand five hundred T ckets
were sold before the match so when it
asks what fraction of the sold tickets
were used what's the whole amount it's
it's the 94501 nomber one you can see
cuz figure number two there's an even
more important ques I'm going to show
you in a second why sometimes it's not
bigger right it's the it's in part a it
says what fraction of and then it says
the sold tickets now have a look at my
um my questions here on the board do you
look up for a second see how it says
what fraction of and then what follows
is whatever the whole amount is what
percentage of our school and that's what
signals to you okay I just look up I
just want to give you any copy you did
to write this down but for instance I
could say mmm just eyeballing it okay I
could say there is a class with 18 boys
and 12 girls this is not us but it's
close enough okay which of these numbers
if I said to you you know some important
of the class which of these numbers is
the whole amount ha now in this case
it's neither of these numbers is it I
actually have to add them together and
get 30 students right
so you have to be really careful with
the numbers I'm sure you can operate on
you kind of calculate it to do most of
that but you need to think carefully
before you answer one okay